per legge pakistana tutti ragazzi e bene
perché questo nuovo video sono fa
vincere ed oggi siamo in un nuovo blog
ragazzi oggi ho avuto la giornata
mentalmente devastante si vede dai
capelli che sono disastrosi e tutto il
resto però ragazzi non lo faccio lo
stesso perché poi la gente se ne esce
dicendo ecco vincendone quando i luoghi
non riesco a stare senza i tuoi video
quindi mi ammazzo nei modi più atroci e
per evitare tutti questi suicidi di
massa lo faccio ugualmente quindi
ragazzi come al solito direi di
cominciare con la fan art della
settimana e questa settimana è stata
vinta da antonio di caprio che ha fatto
questa panart su star john simulator
praticamente sarebbe la copertina
dell'ultimo video di san simone i
tortoise l'alieno quindi grazie mille
veramente soprattutto anche per la
panart perché hai stupendo alla ragazzi
dapprima news di oggi l'avevo scritta
qualche giorno fa anche sulla pagina di
facebook
mettetevi cacia pagani facebook con
ragazzi da quando finito che mario ho
aspettato perché tutti quanti mi state
stressando nel frattempo che usciranno i
prossimi capitoli di cat mario o ha
deciso di fare almeno un giorno alla
settimana o rage game che fosse vostra
scelta quindi a settimana questa
settimana pc stato di map
ogni volta che ci sarà un nuovo episodio
su rage game nei commenti consigliatemi
il regime che volete che io faccio del
prossimo episodio così almeno tutte le
settimane vi potete vedere molto
tranquillo comunque ragazzi un'altra
cosa che volevo dire che almeno un
giorno alla settimana
invito non lo farò quindi invece di fare
sette video su sette giorni ci saranno
tipo sei video su sette giorni e quei
giorni in cui non farò il video dovrebbe
essere o mercoledì o giovedì perché è
nel mezzo della settimana quindi è il
periodo nel quale siamo più tipo
stressati così questo perché i ragazzi
lo sapete già ma per chi non lo sa lo
ripeto quest'anno ho la maturità scende
in quinta e quindi devo devo studiare
veramente tanto e di tempo libero no
veramente molto molto meno quindi per
questo i ragazzi la news brutta ce la
siamo elevata e possiamo non usic e
spero vi piaccia perché mi state marte
l'anno anche su questo venerdì 25 sarò
al gay week di milano così a meno
risposta a tutte le valanghe di commenti
e di domande che mi avete fatto su
questo fa vi ci sarai a milano per il
games week sì ci sarò venerdì 25 non
posso andare sabato perché devo fare
altre cose che non posso dirvi al
momento comunque ragazzi sull organi
suite di milano il 25 è invece il 23
novembre sarò a lucca comics and games 2
tutto il giorno mentre 3 novembre tutta
la mattina fino all'una con ragazzi non
so ancora se metterà un punto di ritrovo
a lucca comics per trovarci tutti quanti
insieme se lo farò lo farò il 3 novembre
ma lo scriverò comunque su facebook
perché ancora non sono sicuro mettetevi
calcio a pagani facebook crisi ragazzi
le news sono finite direi che possiamo
passare allo scarto dei pacchi perché lo
so che lo stanno aspettando tutti i
ragazzi lo so dovevo prendere fiato
[Musica]
madonna perfetto ragazzi oggi ho deciso
di aprirne 3 perché c'è già ero stanco
di mio quindi ho detto compensiamo
almeno quei fatti apriamo non in più
vediamo se anche sta settimana vi dovete
fare sclerare quei pacchi però proseguì
all'apertura non guarda e credimi avevo
intenzione di lasciarlo così grazie
mille è fantastico
passiamo al prossimo button non ha
ovviamente cosa l'apertura ciò che
lascia così ecco test farfa vj verso
schepp mari o con tanto di rescaldina
mammi lo zio ragazzi non state bene un
videogame emozionante ai ragazzi la
coppia venderà molto di più di gta 5
ormai garantito questo non è che
qualcuno perché associa un bazooka per
aprire o no ragazzi perché mi avete
inviato una torta perché perché tutto
questo ma stesso ma non importa tanto me
la mangio tutta io una torta e giornali
dix
[Musica]
che cazzo che figata ragazzi che ha
fatto questo ha vinto tutto tutto ai
pupazzi sui motori sono fantastici
peccato che non c'è scritto il nome
nemmeno sulla carta che ricopriva il
pacco ma ho un indizio è un indizio ha
provato a fare le parole crociate lo
dici verticale fratello maggiore di mosè
ma dj che cos'è cosa iscritta è
sbagliato non le sai ste cose comunque
ragazzi ultimo non per importanza ma per
grandezza
c'è questo che non è da lì che cosa sia
ma scassiamo come se non ci fosse un
domani
abbiamo due poster e aspettate il
quattrocento esageratamente tanta rocce
un nesta in estate
aspettate questa è la nutella più grossa
che abbia mai visti minchia un chilo di
nutella
grazie fratello fa vigente anche stito
famiglia e non bastano quelle normali un
chilo caso è tutto ragazzi il resto a te
l'ho già scritto estate ma la vita è una
cosa assurda e infine c'è più nata una
torcia una torcia
sono terrificanti penso che meritava
cosa che faccio più paura non sia io ma
il brufolo che ciò qui sopra va bè
ragazzi direi che possono includere qui
con lo scarto dei pacchi perché sennò mi
esplode la scrivania non so neanche se
riesco a finire i soldi senza che mi
crolli tutto e quindi ragadi lei di
passare ai fari risponde la prima
domanda arrivata al skyler fare risponde
pensi che sei cambiato dall'inizio dei
tuoi video ad oggi allora non penso di
essere cambiate da allora un pochettino
si comparti che sei un po più timido e
vergognoso perché comunque la fine è una
cosa nuova la fai dall'inizio e quindi
ci vuole un po di diciamo di allenamento
nel senso che ci devi abituare poi dopo
un po che ti sei abituato ma almeno che
fa i video diventi sempre più estroverso
diciamo è a tuo agio quindi
indipendentemente dal numero degli
iscritti fai anche cazzate senza
problemi fa ti faccio vedere la mia
faccia ogni giorno i che è grave ma mi
risponde qui partì la cicatrice di harry
potter e lanci una una volta elevata
afferma hryo vs sei un grande
[Musica]
mario amore
a parte le banda elevata
abate [ __ ] le bacchette cinesi fa
vi risponde perché hanno risponde a
questa domanda durante il blog quali
risponde pari perché non è più coltivato
cooking mama tempo fa avevo fatto un
episodio su cooking mama è pre però non
avevo ancora la wii nel senso non potevo
ancora registrai sono qui lo facevo il
computer col mouse e che veniva brucerà
l'effetto completamente diverso adesso
che ho lauri col telecomando i che vi
voi se volete un episodio su buchi ma va
nel quale spa dello e faccio ste cose
nel caso fatemelo sapere
e sono ben contento di farlo magari
saprò anche una serie se vi piace tanto
non lo so fatemelo sapere nei commenti
va bè ragazzi le domande sono finite
scusatemi sono listino hanno fatto più
risposte ma veramente oggi sono
distrutto e quindi perdonatemi la
prossima volta non parodi più promesso
anche ragazzi se vivo è piaciuto come al
solito lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione
server gl'iscritti iscrivetevi ci
rivediamo il prossimo vito bella ragazzi